for the marlins we'll see how long ross
detweiler goes this is his second start
this year of course he has been a
starter plenty throughout his career
this is number 97 payoff pitch from
detwiler is in there for a called strike
three
big time
a couple of strikeouts here for
detweiler as he sets down cabrera
swing and a miss got him with a fastball
ross detweiler strikes out the side
starting pitcher for the diamondbacks is
the right-hander luke weaver
he was sensational in flirting with a
no-hitter against the reds on april 11th
but since then has struggled really
struggled over his last three starts an
0-2 record an era over seven and a half
he's given up 19 hits in 13 innings 11
runs
another 1-2 this one sent out to left
field coming in peralta and he can't
make the catch
rojas will stop at second
[Applause]
you know fooled a little bit by the
change it catches it off the end of the
bat peralta had a long way to go to try
to make the catch and got himself into
position to do it just didn't secure the
basket catch
now two outs and two on for brian
anderson
that's a base hit up the middle for
brian anderson well not a three-run home
run but he's going to get a ribby miggy
scores and the marlins take a
one-nothing lead
[Applause]
continue to add on here with two outs
runner goes that's a base it up the
middle
and andy's on his way to third
rbi for east san diaz and the marlins
take a two nothing lead
hello beautiful swing from esan and he
continues continues to swing a hot bat
we talked about how many changeups esan
has seen
that was the sixth in this equation six
of seven pitches
changeups and we go to the top of the
order and miguel rojas who walked and
scored the first of the two runs in the
first inning he bats again here in the
second
rojas to center that's gonna get down
this is gonna roll for a while debra's
on his way to third he's gonna get the
green light miggy heading to third base
and he will get there as the ball rolls
around the infield
miggy with an rbi triple
now miggy rowe has found his stroke
i mentioned paul you mentioned the three
for five yesterday i said you know it
was late in the day if you think back it
was three hits in a row he walks his
first at bat now gets another hit
he's been on
five played appearances in a row and
this ball scalded into center field
adam duvall a 385 hitter this year with
two outs and runners in scoring position
luke weaver's pitch is driven out to
left
adam duvall with a bomb to left field
hit one on the money in the first and
cashes in here in the second
hell good for you adam duvall eyes to
the sky hands together almost saying a
prayer as he crosses home plate
celebrating another big swing
a great swing his first time up an even
better swing
in his second at-bat
and that has got to feel good for adam
duvall
[Applause]
and now john curtis the third arm called
upon by don mattingly tonight
so they've been comfortably in front all
game long
97 from curtis
and he beats cabrera
called strike three back-to-back
strikeouts for john curtis
and there are two way
to the right side marlins have a guy
there it's east sandias
a one two three inning for john curtis
the bullpen once again is being clutch
yeah they're putting up zeros
ground ball up the middle maggie behind
the bag up got him at first what a play
what a play miguel rojas
get it done again miggy row wow
my goodness that's when things seem to
kind of quiet down at lone depot park
you've come up with a five-star play
like that wow
made it look easy
curtis
i don't know if he redirected it a
little bit but it certainly looked like
there was a little bit of contact up to
the middle a little bit of a
slump for miggy but
hopefully breaking out of it
sharply hit and that one gets past ahmed
toward the left center field gap sierra
heading to third he's going to get the
green light he can fly an rbi double for
miguel rojas and the marlins are up
seven nothing
and he gets the top speed he's a lot of
great swings from iggy and you're
absolutely right sierra flying around
the bases
even with a little stop and go around
third scores easily i mean this ball
squared up by rojas watch how fast it
gets through the infield
and this finds its way into the gap hits
so hard watch sierra start to fly around
the bases he knows once that gets
through he's moving
maybe just a little pull up on one or
two strides around third and
into score run number seven now adam
duvall
[Music]
that's a base hit into left field adam
duvall had himself a nice night rojas
scores
and it's now an eight nothing marlins
lead
well good to see adam duvall really
swinging it tonight that's quality
advantage picks up another rbi
second hit of the game
zach popp will try to finish this one
off tonight
i wish i had prepared more this is a fly
ball out to left
brinson puts it away brinson has moved
by the way a couple minutes late on this
i apologize i was not coming up with
pitcher names
brinson moved from center to left and
sierra stayed in the field and center
[Music]
to first for aguilar
try it again balling two strikes here it
comes
chopper to the right side aguilar the
flip to pop it's a marlins win eight to
nothing
they get their fourth shutout this year
a bullpen game and a combined shutout
for the marlins